let's go to five headlines
[Music]
all right um let me go to my headlines
if i can here we go
number one another night of the dnc
convention which which
does come to an end tonight and i'm
really excited to be hosting the watch
party uh for that tonight on all access
we'll we'll uh talk about that a little
bit more in fact i'll just tell you
right now
all access live uh you can you can sign
up for that
um it's our most exclusive membership
here over the daily wire is all access
you go to dailywire.com
walsh right now get 20 off all access
with a coupon code access
but tonight at 8 45 p.m we will be
streaming
the um last night of the dnc convention
it's gonna be a big watch party big
celebration
so we're celebrating that it's ending so
make sure to tune in for that anyway
last night obama spoke camilla harris
spoke and um
a lot of people are talking about those
speeches for some reason
what those people don't realize
apparently is that all speeches from all
politicians
are lame and uninteresting
like have you ever so anytime there's a
political speech and people are reacting
to it in this big way
making a big deal of it as people are
with obama's speech you know
but have you ever in your life actually
and maybe there's something wrong with
me
so i'm going to ask you have you ever
heard a a a political
speech in which something was said
that made you go oh wow that's a great
insight
i never thought of it like that in in
your entire life have you ever heard a
political speech that had a moment like
that
i never have and i've heard a lot of
them i've heard non-politicians give
talks and speeches like that but i've
never heard that from a politician ever
so political political speeches are
always telling you everything you
already know
and want to hear or at least what one
side or the other wants to hear
but packaging it in a smoother and more
eloquent way which you know there's a
skill involved in that but
but uh there's there's just there's i
the way people react to political
speeches sometimes i think is there
something wrong with me that i don't see
it because i listen to that and i say oh
yeah well just sounds like every other
speech i've ever heard from a politician
nothing special there uh so we're gonna
skip over most of that but i wanna talk
instead about the biggest speech of the
night
from a non-politician uh the mega star
i'm a huge fan myself
billy eilash was at the convention to
perform and eyelash despite being only
13 14 years old
decided to begin her performance with a
little political lecture for us which i
which this i did hear quite a lot in
this that i thought was a
valuable insight and here it is listen
you don't need me to tell you things are
a mess
donald trump is destroying our country
and everything
we care about we need leaders who will
solve
problems like climate change and kovid
not deny them
leaders who will fight against systemic
racism and inequality
and that starts by voting for someone
who understands how much is at stake
someone who's building a team that
shares our values
it starts with voting against donald
trump and
for joe biden silence is not an option
and we cannot sit this one out
we all have to vote like our lives and
the world depend on it
because they do the only way to be
certain of the future
is to make it ourselves please register
please vote yeah uh really
good stuff there is she standing in a
forest by the way
like that's what i couldn't the whole
time i'm trying to figure out it sounds
like there's crickets in the background
and she's in a like a foggy misty forest
they gave everybody else sound stages
and studios and they made her record in
a haunted forest that seems unsafe
frankly
is this the first address ever given
from a haunted forest at a political
convention that's what i want to know
that would be good trivia i think it
might be if i remember correctly though
we should note
newt gingrich did deliver some remarks
from a serial killer's
shed during the 1992 republican
convention so similar kind of idea but
this time they're out in the forest
um anyway that was that was good and
really i'm rethinking all of my
positions
now after reflecting on what betsy irish
had to say there uh as i said big big
fan of her um
of her music all right let's go to
number two i guess i lied so forgive me
for that i said i wouldn't play any of
the
politicians speeches on second thought i
will play just this one little snippet
i didn't completely lie i guess because
i said that speeches aren't interesting
they don't they don't
contain anything that i haven't heard
before which is absolutely true of this
but still it's notable so listen they
understand that in this democracy
the commander-in-chief does not use the
men and women of our military who are
willing to risk
everything to protect our nation as
political props
to deploy against peaceful protesters on
our own soil yes that would be barack
obama former president
supposedly above it all not mean and
nasty like
old trump the adult in the room right
yes that barack obama and he's making
excuses there for antifa
making excuses for rioters that have
left city blocks in ruins and killed
dozens of people calling them peaceful
that's what we get from from obama who's
just so above he doesn't he doesn't do
all the petty politics
all he's doing is excusing this
dangerous group of people that have you
know
been killing and destroying for for
months now
number three speaking of making excuses
check out these tweets from a guy by the
name of andrew sampson
um he's uh in the tweet he's responding
to someone who says
that they were that their home was
broken into and andrew the compassionate
and empathetic man
says in response because bay area folks
refuse to pay taxes push homeless
shelters out of their neighborhoods
fight against social programs that help
the local populace suffering from
addiction and participate in
gentrification which is skyrocketing up
real estate prices
that's the reason he gives for the uh
for the for the
for the break-in then he continues of
course there is the entitlement and
privilege that comes with all of that
someone breaking into your house should
make you question why they felt that was
their only choice and how the system
failed them translation
you have no right to be upset if your
home is broken into
uh it's partially your fault for living
in that neighborhood and also it's the
system's fault so it's your fault system
it's not the fault of the person who
chose to you know move their legs up to
your door
open the the door or the window or
whatever and come in not their fault
it's everyone else's fault now
if you don't want your home broken into
you're entitled it's probably a good
time now to mention that andrew sampson
is on the forbes
30 under 30 list meaning he's young and
rich
and now it's also also a good time to
mention that the vast majority of
break-ins obviously happen in low-income
areas not surprisingly in low-income
areas
that's where many of the robbers and
burglars live
that's also where the easy targets are
working-class low-income households are
not going to have armed security
probably won't have cameras dogs they
might have one dog but
you know they're not going to have
trained security dogs and so on so this
rich sob is sitting in his
in his safe large protected home telling
you that you're entitled
if you want to be as safe as him that's
what's going on here
and you see how this works this
compassion for criminals
is really just a total lack of
compassion
for victims this is not this is the
absence of compassion
these are people who don't give a damn
about the victims of crime and they
package that sociopathic indifference
and selfishness
in a nice little coding of foe
compassion for criminals
uh last note here i don't know if you've
ever suffered a break-in before
my family has it was a long time ago i
don't remember it i was very young
i wasn't there at the time but my mom
was home
when someone came into the house
probably looking to steal
something presumably i don't know if
they actually did take anything before
running off
but but but here's the point nobody was
physically hurt
nothing of value as far as i know was
taken and yet this is a highly traumatic
experience to have a stranger
in your home violating your safety and
security
in that way to feel all of a sudden
unsafe
and vulnerable in your own home
that's a terrifying experience it's not
a small thing okay it's not the kind of
thing
like if you wake up in the middle of the
night there's someone in your living
room that's not the kind of thing that
you just
oh you know hey the system failed it's
all right i'm gonna go back to bed hey
take what you want
okay you want you want a glass of water
or anything ain't no problem okay
so sleep on the couch great no you don't
do that you
that's that's not the kind of thing you
brush off and andrew sampson
wouldn't brush it off either that's the
attitude he has for everyone else he
says
shake it off rub some dirt on it get
over it you'll be fine
you're [ __ ] and then he retreats behind
his locked gate
with the motion activated cameras that's
the way it goes
number four reading from the daily wire
sweden's top infectious disease expert
warns that believing face masks will
stem the spread of cover 19 is very
dangerous
anders tegnel chief epidemiologist at
sweden's public health agency
basically the equivalent of u.s dr
anthony fauci an
immunologist says there's no proof masks
actually limit the spread of the virus
this is what he says uh it is very
dangerous to believe face masks would
change the game when it comes to covet
19. face mask can be a complement to
other things when other things
are safely in place but to start with
having face masks and then think you can
crowd your buses or your shopping malls
that's definitely a mistake uh and then
he goes on from there like
this just this just shows again how
there's an actual discussion to be had
here about
the efficacy of face masks and how they
should be used
whether they should be used and who
should be using them and what context
they should use
this is something we should really be
talking about but of course like with
everything else
once it is settled meaning that you know
the media and the elites have
decided that this is what it's going to
be that no more discussion is allowed
number five finally this is good stuff
uh jane
lavender assistant editor for the daily
mirror tweets an image a photo from a
book written in the 50s giving
women advice on how to get a man and i
thought you know
in the 50s they really got it they
understood they did
especially on issues related to the
sexes
uh so so they they they understood so
i'm gonna go through this
together we'll all go through this
together and um we'll just see if you're
a single woman
who you know is looking for a man
then i think this might be useful for
you so what we have here is one page i
don't know if she puts up
no yeah it's just the one page and it's
actually 129 ways to get a husband
and here we have you know just uh just
you know 20 or 30 of them so let's go
through a few of them here
okay says number 14 be nice to everybody
they may have an
eligible brother or son good advice okay
no problem there
get a government job overseas
i you know these days i'm not so sure
about it i guess it depends on
i don't know if i would think of that as
a way to necessarily meet someone i
guess you could but it really depends on
where you are
volunteer for jury duty is jury duty
really a place for that kind of
fraternizing i i i would like to think
that it isn't
um be friendly to ugly men handsome is
as handsome does good advice
tell your friends that you're interested
in getting married don't keep it a
secret yeah
that's a big one tell everybody uh write
wear it on a shirt
you know maybe get a shirt made up i'm
interested in getting married
put up a billboard sign in in your in
your community
with your face i'm desperate to get
married something like that
that's gonna advertise and uh the
suitors are gonna show up to your door i
think
maybe not to your door you probably
wouldn't want that but i like this one
get lost at football games
it's great i have been lost at football
games
and i didn't meet any eligible men i
could tell you when i was when i was
lost
mainly because i was ashamed that i was
lost at a football game don't take a job
in a in a company run largely by women
okay here's a good one all right
now we finally got down to business here
so to speak number 20
don't take a job in a company run
largely by women
uh you might argue i'm not i'm not
saying that i'm saying this
i'm not saying that i'm not saying this
either but someone might say
that that is actually good advice in
general for everybody
across time and space some might say
that i've heard some say that
some say it some don't say it that's all
get a job demonstrating fishing tackle
in a sporting goods store
demonstrating fishing tackle in a sporty
this is written by see at first i
thought
this has to be a list written by a man
based on the advice but this advice here
tells me this is a list written by a
woman because this is written by someone
who's never been
in a sporting goods store i've been in
many sporting goods store in my time
i've spent way too much
time and money in them in fact an
embarrassing amount of time and money uh
i've never seen someone there like
demonstrating the fishing tackle
how would you even do that are they
gonna have like a waiting a baby pool
and they're going to have the jig on
there and they're casting in and i what
does that
what would that even look like and
frankly
call me sexist uh if i was asking for
someone to demonstrate it i prefer if it
was a man demonstrating a fishing tackle
this kind of takes me back i went to a
cigar shop not long ago and uh it was
exactly i
again many many cigar shops in my day
again an embarrassing amount of time and
money spent in them
first time in my life i've ever seen a
woman that was there
in explaining all the different cigars
and which hey she has every right to
perfectly fine i'm progressive so i i
was fine with that but
there was a part of me you know there
was
it was a part of me taking a back bite
that's all i'm saying not a negative way
okay so i'm thinking to be the same
thing with a woman demonstrating fishing
tackle so i don't know about this one
um let's see
oh there's any there was a lot of advice
here we'll go through all of this but
carry a hat box
what how would that help what is a hat
box a box with a hat
i guess see this is how
this is why i've got the the 75 iq uh so
you just carry
a ba a box with a hat around
is it a conversation starter like a
man's gotta walk up to you what do you
got there oh a hat box
oh you got a hat box what do you keep in
that a hat
oh well see you later see that's how i
would see that conversation going i
don't know if that's really gonna work
uh and then uh you know oh stand in a
corner and cry softly chances are good
that'll come over to find out what's
wrong
you know what that's that of all of this
that's probably the best advice
on this entire list um
and not bad some good stuff there at
least it's it look
some of this some of it's antiquated at
least a lot of it is better than
probably the advice you get these days
uh you know if you listen to a song like
for example [ __ ]
you know i think this advice is probably
a little bit more applicable in your
everyday life
thank you for tuning in to the daily
wire one of the fastest growing
conservative
outlets in the entire country if you
enjoyed this video be sure to give it a
like and then subscribe to our youtube
channel so you don't miss out on any of
our content